hello everyone and welcome back to the
uh uh rapid action unleashes uh the FED
gr was just finished so we do have some
time for a couple of games um if you
guys have any suggestions on what
openings I should use uh feel free to uh
do so in the comment section below I
will uh try to try to vary but uh for
the moment I'm sticking to my uh okay so
uh our opponent rer or rer uh did not
want to play this game so we're going to
go for another one let me just get rid
of Zen mode we are playing against
psycho Fredo and okay Scandinavian it is
for for the
moment
uh yes our our opponent is from Ukraine
and he knows uh who we are he declines
the Scandinavian okay this should be a
lot of fun so let's
uh I never never tried to learn how to
play the decline Scandinavian uh since
no one ever declines it but here okay my
opponent declined it and now we'll see
how how to play it uh yeah Bishop G4
looks like something you actually should
play but uh it's probably not not all
that
impressive okay let's just continue
development uh
okay yeah it probably would be
okay on
G4
H yeah I don't want to I don't want to
waste a move shifting it back uh so
let's just okay we have a strong Center
we we're going
to uh Advance some pawns on the on the
king side he he castled a bit early so
we're going to try and take advantage of
that okay now I will try to move the
bishop and get my knight to F5 and then
to
G3
and uh trying to keep it very solid I'm
not saying I'm going to Castle Queen
side but I might so we we'll
see um okay let's uh yeah let's just
continue with our plan nothing really
changing
here we might even put the bishop on on
H5 if
needed but yeah so many games in the F
GRS SSS um I haven't covered most of
them of course so if you do have any
that we haven't covered like from board
55 you know maybe some a really awesome
game that no one saw but maybe you know
about it uh please suggest it and I will
very very happily look into
it all right so we're playing sort of
nothing here it's it's the decline
Scandinavian it's it's basically the
opening that does not
exist uh if uh I'm making any any
sense so I mean the Scandinavian is sort
of so bad that you should just accept it
you should just take the pawn on D5 and
then you either get some development in
or you will harass The Black Queen uh
but declining the Scandinavian I don't
know I've seen people do it of
course okay so he goes after the pawn
and
um not really much happening there okay
so we're going to get our Knight to G3
it's a very nice square and uh well it
it it will look very nice here uh it's
going to stop me from attacking pretty
much uh for a very long time uh but
okay um yeah let's put the Knight
there all right let's go Queen
B6 I might even since I'm not expecting
any action on the king side I might even
just move the bishop and hide my king
here yeah okay that's uh
interesting yeah I I I could go to A6
although the queen isn't really doing
all that much on A6 so I will have to
yeah I'm kind of looking forward to C4
at some point I if I could get my Bishop
to this diagonal would be great but for
the moment that's not happening so he is
forcing me to play uh to play
D4
uh yeah
okay not too happy about
that since our Bishop isn't a very good
piece now uh but okay let's play Bishop
D7 and and slowly get our pieces into
the
game okay so it's uh it's a big nothing
of a position and I have to figure out
how to activate
uh any of my
pieces okay so uh now now obviously we
can capture our Bishop here isn't an
amazing piece but it is guarding the C5
Pawn so do I get anything from this is
he doing anything with the Knight here
not really the Knight isn't really a
huge part of this game he he can put it
here and then it's going to be sort of a
nuisance but yeah let's not open up the
file just
yet and if he moves the dark Square
Bishop from E3 I can always REM maneuver
my knight
here and my opponent says feel free to
pause the video here okay obviously he
he's either joking or he he found some
very nice move all right so what did we
miss anything I'm not seeing any Knight
E6 or F5 if he does have knight6 or
F5 um I don't see
it
okay so yeah okay he wins The Exchange
okay he wins The Exchange but then we
win the E3 Square it's
fair yeah I really thought I had
everything covered but I'm still not
convinced that this will be all that
impressive
okay yeah let's go
here the E3 square is ours for the
taking and we do have the bishop pair so
objectively he is probably better but uh
we will we will do our
best let's kick away one of the knights
is B4 a
move yeah probably even B4 is a move
now okay so he is uh definitely in the
lead but we will figure out a way out of
this
Perhaps Perhaps we
will he has to figure out what to do
with the Knight does he move it does he
play B4 does he then my knight will come
here okay he's going to play
B4
um h
yeah not not the best okay but we will
put a knight
here now he has to sort of be a little
bit careful uh with my knight Queen
combo here uh but okay as long as the
Rook is on the second rank nothing to
worry about really so I will be looking
into maybe somehow moving the bishop and
getting my Rook into the
attack if possible and he of course yeah
I thought maybe okay I could challenge
the pawn but he would very happily open
up the the a file for his Rook so we're
not even going to look at
that okay so
A3 makes
sense let's go
here yeah if he gives a chck back that's
nothing okay of course he will undermine
the
pawn
uh okay we'll worry about that when it
when it gets to that so probably he will
take
now uh but still no no good way to
attack the Knight and the only good way
to attack the queen is to go here and
then we can also take the D3 point so he
will have to waste at least one more
move
oh okay that is something I did not take
into
consideration but that means my knight
will remain there for a very long time
okay even
that okay
fine the other Knight may now take its
place okay fair fair enough
enough uh okay
um
H question is do I like my dark Square
Bishop that's the that's the only
question here I like it at least to
guard this Pawn at some point in the
game
might even play C5 now just to be just
to be extra
annoying yeah I don't even have to ruin
my Pawn structure here I could yeah he's
going to play C5 all right we're going
to bring this one into the
attack uh also trying to be very
annoying here now also this is a threat
okay so he defends against that now how
to get this used useless Queen into the
game this is uh this is the definition
of a useless
Queen yeah we can't go in through via
light
squares wow this is uh really
tough this is really
tough it's tough to even find a useful
move
here
yeah let's move the
Rook move the Rook I don't think I have
any
anything okay so he will
take
why okay so of course he can play that
but this uh perhaps helps me a little
bit before he did this I had no okay so
he does have pressure on that pawn if I
play G5 okay let's get the queen here
first sort of
defend and now we we Bank everything on
G5 okay so now he's ready he wants
to uh he wants to give up the the The
Rook for Knight and sort of get back
into the game but I will keep it
there is this a move Knight G4 check is
this a move if he takes I get my Pawns
in and
then it's not the best yeah it's not the
best but considering everything could be
the best that I
have no it's
not nothing
really
h
oh yeah not a big fan of giving up the
Knight either
way but it's sort
of sort of better to do it this
way
yeah let's take it and let's yeah we
still can't play that G5 move he's
constantly going at
it yeah
okay
now now it's a pretty big problem
but it's not like we had anything better
okay let's go
here yeah and we go okay so now he wants
to he wants to advance the pawn and
doesn't seem to be a way for us to
handle that
yeah I think that could be could be
it for
us
yeah he's just going to push and play
Rook e three ah this is so bad so
bad yeah I have to I have to defend
like poorly here but okay if we can if
we can take it into a queen and pawn end
game uh we can still maybe play yeah we
have to play it like
this then it's still sort of a
game not really he's uh completely
winning here uh but uh we can at least
hope
yeah that wasn't uh that wasn't the best
game not at
all okay
so let's defend this Pawn here okay if
he captures I can just yeah he wants he
wants this this this this and mate since
the pawn is covering this um
so we're just going to do
nothing although that's not easy to
achieve yeah it's actually okay we can
we can play this now if he takes I can
capture with the pawn and this Pawn is
defended sort of still keeping me in the
game but I'm I'm wasting too much time
finding moves as there there really
aren't any so we'll see how how quickly
he can
take take the full point interestingly I
haven't captured a single one of his
pawns that's very
interesting okay so we're just going to
go here yeah no we're not no we're not
but we can play this
now sort
of pretend his Rook is misplaced here
although it's really not he'll just play
this yeah but it's uh the best I had
it's the best I
had okay so now we can go here it's
nothing really but at least he's giving
me a little bit of space to work with
he's not uh ending it right away he's
going to go here will
he see if he gives me one more move I'm
already in drawing territory if I can
somehow get my queen here and sacrifice
maybe
something yeah so long way to
go he'll probably push the pawn okay so
he he invites me in
okay very
nice go
here probably some check here should end
the game
okay so can I survive here for one more
move maybe I
can all
right me maybe if our opponent isn't uh
isn't careful maybe we can even get some
sort of a some sort of a draw
here all right of course he will do that
uh he wants to get what what does he
want he wants to get the queen
in
okay uh well I'm out of time so I will
take it yeah I was uh sort of uh
looking at that yeah I have to play
this yeah it's m in one no it's not oh
if this actually have
this yeah this is disgusting yeah let's
go
here let's go
here okay I will I will go with the King
okay now it's getting interesting I have
18 second but my king is going
places this very strange do I have some
maybe even some potentially tricky stuff
here uh he will probably just flag well
he wants to yeah I have to take this
otherwise he's just going to give a
check trade queens and that's all there
is
okay really out of time
here just avoiding some checks maybe
threatening some checks if he stops this
check I can threaten this one oh this is
getting uh way too close for
comfort okay so now we go now we go in
for the kill that's mate wow
unbelievable unbelievable good game Mr
psycho
Fredo uh I played I played absolutely
terrible disgusting chess but uh you
know one thing we can take from this
game is that you should never give up
and sometimes your opponent will maybe
just give you that one little chance uh
where you can sort of find a way to
survive for one more move and then uh
win the game in a disgusting fashion
like this uh so yeah I hope you enjoyed
enjoyed it uh that was a pretty pretty
long game 20 minutes but uh you know we
persevered and it paid off uh so uh
thank for watching I will see you soon
and if you have a suggestion on what
opening to use or what game to show uh
always use hasht suggestion um uh in the
comment section below so uh thank you Mr
psycho Fredo for this wonderful game and
thank you for allowing me to get sort of
back into the game and uh well in the
end it was the most time trouble uh but
yeah um very glad I was able to pull
this off uh so yeah once again hope you
enjoyed it uh I uh you can check through
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day